I know you were listening to the trans
box secretary secretary there what did
you make of what he was saying
fortunately it came across as just the
same rhetoric which has become really
tired and certainly not moving the
discussions on
um for for our nursing staff and we are
a matter of days now before the next two
days of action and so the rhetoric has
to change they need to get around a
table and start to have negotiations
proper meaningful negotiations with me
on behalf of those nurses and you know
coming out with the same stuff saying
they value nurses and again the absolute
over emphasis about their pay review
body and which seems to have become
seriously more important to them than
fixing the crisis in the Health Service
and protecting the Health Service and
actually getting a resolution to the
strike and I guess the argument that Mr
Harper was making is that the pay Rises
would be unaffordable he says first
Lucas it would embed High higher pay
rises in the system so Stoke inflation
and also saying that in the private
sector people are getting pay Rises of
just four to five percent so it's
unaffordable and unfair for taxpayers
well that's that's
um I'm not saying that he's not telling
the truth but
um factually that's not right we sounds
like you are saying well we we carried
out
um got independent economics to carry
economists to carry out
um a very comprehensive economic study
comparing
um pay Rises within the public sector
particularly for nurses against those in
the private sector and it became
abundantly clear within the report that
the private sector pay has increased
significantly with
um a pay Rises and pay increases that
have certainly
um been
um at the almost looking enviously I
think within the Health Service you
would say that he's effectively cherry
picking the figures then just looking at
the last year rather than looking back
over many years yes and I think that's
not the right thing to do in the current
crime is that we find ourselves
ourselves in
um you originally asked for a 19 rise
now you're saying that's just a starting
point so are you willing to compromise
and to come down on that then well look
I think I I'm I'm on the record for
saying that we had never put a 19
um figure on it however we did certainly
set out our policy position as five
percent above the rate of inflation
um at the time that we obviously
um agreed the policy position inflation
wasn't where it was um in the current in
the current times
um however everyone knows that the
college and myself as the general
secretary has um not just extended an
olive branch but in fact I think we've
leaned the whole Tree in at this stage
to say meet us halfway get us around a
negotiating table I'll set out my stall
for the 300 000 plus nurses that to put
part in this ballot and they can do the
same and let's let's let's find a way
through the current crisis that we find
ourselves in the meeting halfway would
it be fair to assume around the 10 mark
look that's what you've been reporting I
can't negotiate a certain time and time
again I'm not going to negotiate on the
airwaves I I can't negotiate at a table
on my own and the only table I can
negotiate at is a table with the prime
minister or with the secretary of state
and I would urge them again a matter of
days from the next strike to please do
that for every single member of nursing
staff that absolutely deserve to be
heard not talked about on the airwaves
by the Prime Minister by the Secretary
of State but talk to them through at a
table with me they owe that to nursing
but they owe it to patients as you say
strong action just a matter of days away
now we heard the train drivers Union
saying that the chances of a deal he
would put at zero to call off his
strikes would you put yours any higher
like every single nurse listening um to
this program now and listening over this
last months we live in optimism that's
something that at some stage that sense
will be brought to these discussions by
this government so I'm not going to sit
here and lose hope
um there's hope for the next number of
days that we can get to a table and that
we can start negotiating
um I'm in communication with the
secretary of state I'm hopeful that the
next time him and I find ourselves at a
table that the discussion will be will
be different and that we will start to
talk realistically about how we can
bring things to to a conclusion you say
you have optimism is there any reason
for that optimism has anything changed
the tone the messaging or is there
anything behind it well we we certainly
had optimism after listening to the
Prime Minister over the weekend
um and a
um on that basis yes we thought look
there must be something that that can be
addressed for 22-23 pay for our nursing
staff because that's where the dispute
is
um unfortunately as as time went on
through the week we heard on on on the
media that uh there were some
discussions about one-off payments and a
back data payment but um those those
have never been put to me either
formally or informally but it's the
wrong place to have those discussions
they owe it to nursing staff to get
around a table and have those
discussions with me formally would are
there those things I know you don't want
to negotiate on the Airways but could
you see a deal forming around those
principles
whatever is put to me needs to be
significant that's the first thing it
needs to be it needs to have long-term
thinking behind it and it needs to have
long-term investment and one-off
um ill thought through payoffs isn't
going to do this but look let's get to a
negotiating table and let's start to
really fundamentally talk about what
will resolve the strike for the for our
nursing staff so it sounds like a
one-off payment I wouldn't cut it but
how about looking at you know the next
pay-per-view 2020 2023 onwards let's get
to a table and let's let's have a
conversation understood how long could
the strikes last for until we get a
resolution for our nursing staff that so
deserve it and every single member of
our nursing profession deserves more
they deserve better and they don't
deserve to be treated like this by this
government and they are saying clearly
to me on a daily basis that this
government has turned their back on them
um a profession that carried us through
the pandemic and long before it the
nursing profession is in crisis as a
consequence of how they've been treated
we have long waiting lists the Health
Service it's well documented is in
crisis the only way to resolve the
crisis in Health Service is to actually
retain and recruit our brilliant nurses
that we have got keep them and and
recruit more in and that can only be
done by this government sitting down and
talking to me but you're saying that
you'll keep going with strong action
until you get what you want I believe
our nursing staff will
um they believe that this is their
opportunity to speak up on behalf of
their patients and try and do something
to address the Staffing levels 40 seven
thousand vacant posts in this country
alone and every single nurse coming on
duty night and day feel that but more
importantly our patients feel it so this
is our time to speak up and have our
voice heard on behalf of our patients
and that's what every nurse is trying to
do now this is a really difficult
question to ask you but I am like
interested on your opinion on it do you
feel that the strong action is putting
lives at risk
well we heard from the Royal College of
emergency medicine but I think every
nurse knows this that there are
unnecessary deaths as a consequence of
the NHS crisis it's not our nursing
staff that are putting patients lives at
risk most certainly not and I think the
Secretary of State actually admitted
himself that on the days of strike
action the Royal College of Nursing
um delivered that action with a very
safe and steady hand and there was
nothing Reckless about how we managed to
do that we Exempted emergency and Urgent
Care Services from our strike we'll
continue to do that and we will do
nothing that will add any further risk
or any further unsafe care to our
patients that's what we're about and
that's what we'll continue to do and
just finally what kind of things are
nurses seeing in the NHS right now just
give it as a sense of how you see the
state of NHS the NHS and I've been a
nurse for 42 years and I speak to it to
um our profession every single day they
would say that they it was it was
difficult during a difficult being
um a word that I'm using likely during
the pandemic but this that's nothing
like like it is it's absolutely worse
worse than June they are working in an
incredibly
um fragile critical state every single
day with a very depleted Workforce but
they themselves are emotionally
psychologically and physically depleted
having gone through two years of the
pandemic and they are working excessive
hours very very long hours and very
unsafe conditions unsafe so people are
dying unnecessarily as well well we've
heard from from the Royal College of
emergency medicine people are dying
unnecessarily and that's not the way we
want our patients to be treated it's not
how the people of this country should be
treated and we need we ought to be doing
better we ought to be doing
um delivering a Health Service that
actually is the Envy of the world but
unfortunately I believe this government
has not just let patience down and are a
profession down but actually they're
letting the NHS die thank you very much
indeed good to talk to you